[Music]
good
afternoon ladies and gentlemen welcome
to strasbourg for the european
parliament for the
opening ceremony on the conference of
the future of
europe it's uh over to you
european citizens to take your future in
your hands and you will be
the actors across
europe of in finding solutions
which can be developed over the
2021-2022
welcome on this 9th of may
this corona proof europe day the day
that more than 70 years ago
marked the beginning of the idea of a
european union with the schumann
declaration
the day that symbolizes europe's
striving for peace
and unity it's a work that's still in
progress
like rome europe was and is not
built in one day
europe is not built in a day this is
what schuman himself said and today
we're going to prove this to you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
then
[Music]
[Music]
what you just saw was a fast forward run
through europe's history and the 360
degrees
look at the many faces experiences
and realities that make up the european
union
it's been and still is in a way a story
of
hardships and dreams of setbacks
and achievements
today europe day the 9th of may we are
here in the seat of the european
parliament here in strasbourg france
we are in the very hemi cycle where the
meps usually sit with some a very
important guest we have the
emmanuel macron the french president the
president of this parliament david
tasoli
prime minister antonio costa from
portugal which is currently has the
presidency of the european council
we also have the president of the
european commission ursula van der line
we also have the three presidents of the
executive
board of the conference on the future of
europe
we also have with us 27 erasmus students
and you can see on your screens the 27
ministers of european affairs and 500
citizens who are also here with us
there's a
a lot of good will to start this
conference there will be a series of
debates
and also discussions led by citizens and
should allow
everyone to share their ideas and
to build our common future together this
is done
via a digital platform in 24 languages
indeed but for this project
to succeed it needs you europeans to
breathe
life and impact into it to really make
it a tool for a more democratic european
union covet laid their
weaknesses of and in the eu these past
few years or months at least but it also
highlighted some strengths and room for
improvements the pandemic may well
inspire
a wide range of suggestions for change
today the political leaders of the eu
are present here and they're here
to tell you to explain why and how they
started this conference
or conversation if you like and what it
should lead to
we will begin by welcoming president
macron
i'm very pleased i'm sure that we are
here in the seat of the european
parliament which has not
been used by
the meps for 12 months now mr president
you have the flaw to open the ceremony
and maybe you could also give us
your view on the future of europe
thank you
thank you mr president of the european
parliament uh madam president of the
european commission
prime minister ladies and gentlemen
ministers
madam vice president of the european
commission ladies and gentlemen meps
ladies and gentlemen
both in the room today
and from afar through remote
conferencing
i am quite a happy man to see you
that we can gather once again together
today
during this europe day i'm very pleased
that we're celebrating
with a shared political commitment uh
orchestrated by what will become our
universal language the artists
are willing to play their part and here
we are gathered in strasbourg on
the 9th of may which tells us a great
deal about who we are
how we're going to work to shape
ourselves after the 70 years of a common
experience
and looking at the founding moments in
our archives strasbourg is the city
of reconciliation after all it is the
living symbol of this europe
that said no to war to build peace
to replace occupation with cooperation
to lift the worries of looking towards
the borders uh
to breathe new confidence and friendship
into
european souls that's what strasbourg is
all about strasbourg
the capital of europe is a symbol
and we're not building an imaginary
europe but we're
building this feeling of belonging
strasbourg is the home to
what it is uh in its democratic efforts
of outreach
and not just looking to the past uh but
inspired
by it to build the future this is where
the european heart beats
the council of europe the european
parliament
uh the parliament that unites us not a
weakness but certainly uh
it allows us to show our strength and to
affirm our identity
so president david thank you for being
here today with this firm decision now
to
start with the european parliament's
work once again in strasbourg as soon as
possible
we discussed this at great length before
this is
a founding chronic of time
that we just witnessed together and this
should lead us
it should inspire us to basically
grow accustomed to the current situation
but
to overcome the weaknesses but to remain
permanently optimistic and driven
that is our duty and we need to breathe
a new democratic life
into our institutions and to build that
confidence
that we have in europe amongst our
citizens
we are here in an unprecedented pandemic
that has affected us for more than a
year worldwide but
most particularly in europe
when these huge crises fall upon us
and we've had many many such occurrences
in the past
there are always uh very deep-seated
doubts and national instincts uh that
start to make themselves comfortable
we've seen today
that some people are challenging what we
are about
who we are and just
forgetting everything that we've built
up that's what's at stake today
that's the risk of that is to just give
up out of a
a sense of just not knowing what to do
rather than to build on what we've done
and we can always hear people attack
europa
accuse it through this uh spirit of
defeatism
look at this europa europe and miss the
boat
and i say it's quite the opposite in
this crisis it is a european model that
really
came into its own and i think we've seen
the pathways forward given the
challenges before us
this model is our dna our deep identity
i want
basically in inaugurating this
conference although we've talked about
the decades ahead i wanted to recall
that if together we managed to resist
in the face of this is because for 70
years now we have built together
which we didn't just happen it wouldn't
have just have happened by itself
without real effort through our model of
social protection
a europe characterized by solidarity it
is the result
of a model that is productive and social
a europe of competitiveness of
competition
of economic strength but it is always
thought in terms of solidarity from the
word go
solidarity towards the region so towards
the local communities
and in terms of ambitious policies
nowhere else in the world do we have
so much uh importance attached to life
and we're happy with that and on a
continent
when lives are sacrificed in order to
preserve the economy sometimes that
wasn't possible
we made that choice in europe to show
our solidarity a
humanitarian face and we accompanied
everybody along the way with our health
care system which we funded
together we helped our businessman's our
independent workers industrialists in
all sectors the most hardly hit
and we have every reason to be proud of
what we've done would it just have
happened the poor countries of course
very
strongly hit even uh the other
continents are trying to act
were forced to sacrifice lives quite
simply to keep
the economy going otherwise the crisis
would have made more victims
other countries have sacrificed many of
their
economic models they don't have the same
solidarity model
we think of our friends in our allies in
america
our model is our strength and we've
managed
to resist together we've managed to come
up with a rapid response
together given the crisis that started
10 years ago
an immediate reaction a rapid budgetary
response over the european spots of july
last year
and together we built a vaccination
campaign we put it together
we made it happen and i would like to
thank the president of the commission
we did not have that community
competence at the beginning of this
crisis
we got our act together we managed
to decide to
gain pace to gain momentum and yes
european cooperation did save
lives and will continue to do so that's
our strength and yes this model of
solidarity is the one
that from the very beginning of the
crisis has allowed us
to rekindle our faith in solidarity
through the initiatives
with our african partners with vaccine
solidarity with our
balkan neighbors and continuing to build
on that solidarity we're happy
i'm pleased that with our american
allies they're joining us now on this
path
to help us in our endeavors to open up
to export to doses uh the transfer of
technology
to produce more vaccines and
particularly to send
it to all who need it this cooperation
this spirit of solidarity is bigger than
any of us it is what
leads us with our neighbors and
particularly our african neighbors
to build the decades ahead of us our
second
major strength once again
became clear during this crisis and i
don't think you can possibly say it
enough
it's democracy which is part of identity
and despite it all insidiously more and
more
it is being called into question people
are wondering how effective it is
i hear like you do the voices of those
who
are in authoritarian regimes they
haven't been very effective
in this crisis they haven't managed too
well
basically it's what our citizens expect
of us
and of course if we forget the real
consequences of the authoritarian
regimes
the lack of freedom more and more
political detainment uh uh university
professors are being
stifled it's not just academic they've
forgotten
that uh they are part of history those
that chose to embark on that path but we
have every reason to be happy
to carry on to openly discuss
and to conduct in our democracy
everywhere in europe
this democratic debate the criticism
challenging
the fights quarrels disagreements is
what defines us
and it's also what makes us more
effective
it allows us to express criticism
democratically
this model which is productive
and shows solidarity part of our
european id
being attached to protecting the
environment and the climate and we
maintain that ambition thoroughly
during the crisis through the green deal
and through the digital platforms
and protection of privacy respecting the
rights and freedoms of strasbourg
is the place of many symbols because of
the battles that we have waged
during the pandemic it is a model
based on an economic and social system
that has shown that
it is resilient in times of crisis and
yesterday and the day before in porto
we saw that uh to adapt to the
transition
to the digital era and with genuine
protection for our workers uh allowing
us
to grow to create jobs which goes hand
in hand
with fighting exclusion poverty and
promoting
gender equality the respect of
fundamental rights of all workers
in all value chains that is our model
and i want to recall that before we
start thinking about the 10 years ahead
of us
never can we allow it to become
vulnerable it is a treasure that we have
earned that we have built over time in
this crisis
it does show some cracks of weakness
and europe has to be able
to do things and our aspirations are
that we're entitled to
should be based on what the causes of
the crisis
were first of all we understood the
message it is solidarity
that goes hand in hand with sovereignty
you cannot have a model based on
solidarity
uh you cannot be helping those who
are the weakest in our society if we
don't
produce if we don't decide to defend the
sovereignty of our space
we were divided at the beginning for
some time when it came to purchasing
masks
shutting our borders at times even for
the recovery
we got divided whenever we were
dependent
each and every time we were up against
a risk in the response when it wasn't in
our hands
we managed to ensure that sovereignty
was the ability to produce today and
tomorrow
and i don't think that we will have a
europe that's
up to it's
dating history and that's what we
realized that in the uh 1980s and 90s
and in the
2000s we were a larger consumer market
and we are still today and we need to
once again
become producers we need to become once
again
a community of major scientists to large
entrepreneurs major artists
industrialists
because production creating on our
territory
is guaranteeing our sovereignty
protecting our model
and our values and it is this
sovereignty
this cultural academic industrial
research sovereignty is crucial
building it is sometimes meaning winning
back things that we allowed to slip
through our fingers and sometimes
strategically coming up with a response
by seeking alliances the european
industrial alliances as we've started
once again with a hydrogen
semiconductors of the cloud
managing what we've done in a matter of
times to become
the number one vaccine producer
worldwide
but we need to go far further because
each and every time there's
dependence on the external world europe
is divided
we also learned during this crisis our
second lesson
when europe has the ability and the
resilience to act
you do once you were driven by the
political motivation as of march
2020 the european central bank was up to
the task
and suspended uh the vegetarian
competition
rules which allowed us uh to state our
desire to get the economy going again
but in many areas the european union
doesn't have the same competence or the
same wherewithal
and sometimes it really has very little
to work with
in the field of health and that's still
the case today
this weakness explained the difficulties
in coordination
therefore we need to learn the lessons
given this major shock of the pandemic
we need to beef up our common capacity
because it is at the european level
that will come up with the relevant
response and finally
we've noted oftentimes that europe
wasn't moving forward
quickly enough was lacking ambition
in this very hemicycle i stated my
conviction that in dealing with
authoritarian regimes
the only valid response is the
authority of democracy and you can only
get that
if you are effective and quick our
european democracy is one of compromise
of
striking a balance and that's something
we need to protect like a treasure
because it avoids any hegemony it is
also a weakness that when
we are strangled in our own procedures
there is no fatality in the procedures
but once again
we need to find an effective way forward
with ambition to get through the crises
and to avoid
uh not taking decisions we need to be
stronger looking at the figures of our
program our research investment program
on industrial projects for the future if
you compare
what we've done with the us or china
we're not yet where we need to be
up to our ambition and too many months
have taken
to finally get the investment decisions
that are five or ten times
lower compared to our us counterparts in
other terms
i'm pleased that the united states of
america looks to europe to become
more of a society of solidarity and i
hope in my deepest of hearts that in
europe
we will once again find faith in the
future and act
swiftly for massive investments acting
on these investments
and therefore it is our duty to pull
this
off to act more quickly and
to find the relevant subjects uh to gain
that momentum
this crisis has affected us in our most
intimate uh
parts of life our private lives imposed
uh limits on our travel at the borders i
see many young europeans
faces i see artists
who have suffered a great deal during
this crisis
because they have had their
concert rooms taken away from them their
contact with the public
stripped away from them and i think that
at this conference it is essential
we need to find the path towards the
future once again
and that is what this conference on the
future of europe is all about
to find a way to shape democracy
collectively
and to learn the lessons and i haven't
even covered all of them
but also to find the ways and means
once again to find the long-term outlook
a real
genuine outlook based on shared
objectives
our friends are the most involved uh i
would like to thank them at this time
but there will be a year of a debate
where we'll meet one another the
institutions the parliamentary the
social partners uh
and we know how very much they want to
be a
part of this discussion uh uh the
thinking groups of all citizens uh
european groups at the local level the
online platforms available in all
languages a citizen's panel
it will be an unprecedented exercise
to listen to the entire continent and to
think
of what we want our future to look like
from the beginning in
autumn we had the citizens debate in
each region i asked the heads of
government to get involved
we need to make a collective commitment
today
as soon as march of 2022 when we look at
all of the contributions put it all
together
sum it all up we political decision
makers and the various member states the
european parliament the european
commission
will have to take that into account and
inform europa
and picking up on what uh we did in the
first
half of 2022 in the uh presidency
organizing a conference that uh we hope
will continue with this and we need
everybody to be on board with
a full commitment this conference is
something we owe to our young people
we ask them to make the hardest to
sacrifice during this crisis after all
and it is for them that we will build
this new europe when i spoke of all
these values in our success it's because
we have the privilege
of having the years of struggle
sometimes dangerous and horrible
struggle over the years and for our
young people once again
we need to have a confidence uh where
they have their rightful place
today there is a broad online
consultation process underway with 50
000 young people telling us what their
priorities are
uh what their aspirations are their
priorities
their dreams and as of this autumn
we'll take a new youth initiative once
again in a very real sense like to
support
students to find their way back to the
classrooms uh
and to help those uh who have launched
on in building a new business
each and every one to have such a new
experience
in another country thanks to the
european commission the european
investment banker
through national means uh additional
relaunch
measures that's how we're going to do it
and on the substance uh
we'll you will have to write that
chapter in the history books
i hope that this conference will
sound off the time of major projects
major ambitions major dreams what do we
want europe to look like in 10
15 years what borders will it have what
new institutions
what major cultural projects will we
launch
together how can we make this europe
the leader of reduction of emissions
and i hope carbon neutrality achieved
even more quickly
how can we build this europe of
education of research making it even
stronger
the new borders in space
in our oceans how can we manage
basically to write our new legends for
ourselves
a french poet who's been often
overlooked
patrice electro de pa said it
all countries that have lost their
legends
will be condemned to die of the cold
and that will apply to our europe as
well if we lose sight of our legends we
will die
of called we have our legends
and we need to go through them quickly
we need to write new legends
it is up to us it is up to you
thank you and i'm counting on you
and while we are getting the stage ready
for the
karski quartets let us take the
opportunity to explain to you
how you can participate in the
conference
that we just heard about to begin with
you can submit your ideas for change
your worries your questions on our
website
future future eu dot europa
dot eu
there are also events which will be
organized in
all member states in your regions either
um by digital means
or otherwise there will be panels which
represent different
areas and different parts of society
there will be different topics which
will be taken into account and then
these will be fed back into the plenary
conference
in the eu institutions there's also
social
partners and obviously all europeans
it's getting readier
and readier for the karski quartet
they're up next
let me tell you a little bit about them
they're a multinational quartet
originating in belgium they're
multinational because it's one belgian
and
three polish musicians working together
in the universal language that music
is they took their name from
jankarski he's a legendary figure in the
resistance
or he was a legendary figure in the
resistance during the second world war
and the quartet is particularly inspired
by kursky's
profound compassion and uncompromising
attitude
they will be playing for as the
number one quarter number one open 76
of joseph hayden
it was described at the time as full of
innovation
and full of fire uh innovative
now you soon will be able to judge it
for yourselves if
that is still true we'll allow our
musicians
our quartet to take their places and
whenever you're ready
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
is
[Music]
so
bravo
bravo to the casket quartet and now
in his very own hemi cycle in the
capital of the alzas
i think this is a capital which very
close to your heart
i think you appreciate local cuisine uh
i think that's uh
one reason but other reasons as well
david cecilia you are the president of
the european parliament
you are i fervent defender of
uh the the role of this conference
you're a former
uh journalist in italy you've always
tried to listen
to the people and you need to have this
discussion
with this uh house at this um
house which is uh elected by direct
um democracy and we need to
invest in the future you are calling on
european citizens to
mobilize what message would you like to
give to them
thank you and good afternoon to everyone
president macron
president fonda lyon prime minister
costa
ministers of foreign affairs
colleagues citizens ladies and gentlemen
let me welcome all of you here
to the european parliament for the
opening ceremony
of the conference on the future of
europe which is being held on europe day
it was important for this major
democratic exercise
to be launched here in the hemi cycle of
the home of european citizens here in
strasbourg
the seat of our institution
from which we've been absent for so many
months as a result of the covid19
pandemic we trust
and hope that the parliament will very
soon be able to return
its plenary sessions here
in strasbourg i'd like to thank
president macron
for his presence and for his
involvement in this important issue
and i'd also like to thank the joint
presidents of the conference
president from the lion and prime
minister koster
this hybrid opening ceremony and i'd
like to welcome all
european citizens who are connected
here today from our member states
i'd like to thank the
ministers of european affairs the 20
the leaders of political groups
and the high representative for foreign
security affairs
there are many many people connected
with us
today and unfortunately we can't all be
physically
in this room as a result of the pandemic
and over the last
months we've seen a lot of pain among
our citizens
our families our workers
as a result of covid at the start of
this parliamentary term
as you're aware the conference on the
future of europe was a priority for the
european parliament
we requested it and it's being launched
today
yes there has been a delay but an awful
lot has happened during recent months
even before the pandemic the parliament
firmly believed in the importance
of having an event such as this today
after 15 months of crisis
it's very clear to us what has worked
and what hasn't worked
it's much clearer to us where the
european union
is strong and what we can be proud of
but we're also aware of where we're weak
and what we could improve
the lessons we've learnt from kovid are
important ones for all of us
and they're also important for the
functioning of the european union
during the last 15 months
we've had the same institutions
and the same individuals in place and
yet some things haven't worked haven't
worked and some have
when europe is aware of its
responsibilities
it responds effectively rapidly
coherently but when
the european union finds itself
in a difficult situation
then sometimes it finds itself in
difficulties
we want to improve the way in which we
function
and we want to base ourselves on our
values and principles to do that
because we firmly believe that democracy
is stronger than
authoritarianism and provides more
effective responses it respects
individuals communities and member
states
and that's why we need to get down to
work
as of today to ensure that we function
in a more
consistent manner europe
needs to have a clear remit clear
competencies
in many areas areas in which
member states alone would be
marginalized and would simply struggle
we need to think of ourselves we need to
think
of democracy
we need to make it capable of taking
rapid decisions
because our citizens want democracy to
respond to their needs
but if democracy has to decide
unanimously
if there can be vetoes how can the
european union respond effectively
we need to work on ourselves
because we want to leave
our younger generations not only
the weight of the crisis but pride
in a european union which can be a
reference point
in a world where the challenge
of authoritarianism is a major one
and we see that on the international
stage at this time
this year has been a year
of lessons learned
and we shouldn't simply stash them away
in a draw somewhere
we need to look at them and understand
how and where
we can improve this
ceremony is launching this process
and we have a need
to move forward with this exercise
of this unprecedented exercise in
democracy
institutions and citizens institutions
and civil society
european institutions and national
institutions all need to work together
because another lesson in the crisis
is that we are all part
of the same whole the european union
isn't only brussels it's national
parliaments
its national governments regions as well
which are so important in the lives of
our countries
everyone needs to feel involved in this
process
and we want to work with them
we want this
conference we'll discuss
the way we are without taboos we want
clear pragmatic suggestions as to how we
can improve
the parliament obviously intends to play
its role
in this conference as
the representative of our citizens
our 705 members of the european
parliament
feel a major responsibility in ensuring
that this exercise will be a success
they will be reaching out to citizens
and to voters
who've placed their faith in this
institution
a year and a half ago
the temptation was to undermine
the european union in the elections
but citizens were aware that joint
policy european policy and a spirit of
solidarity
would enable us to overcome major
difficulties
for the european parliament
we need clear proposals at the end of
this procedure
based on recommendations made by
citizens and debates
in the plenary assembly but the most
important thing
is that these suggestions be followed by
action
these proposals will have to be a
compass
to guide our work during the coming
decade
and by signing the joint declaration
our institutions committed themselves
along those lines
without wishing to prejudice the results
of these debates
the conference will be a space for
discussion in which
will inevitably have to tackle the issue
of european health
as president macron said and as the
parliament has already said
we need a european policy
on human health as a result of the
pandemic if we don't
achieve that it would be a defeat and it
would mean exposing ourselves
to new crises and new difficulties
we've just held the porto summit and i
believe
that the social dimension will also be
at the heart of the discussions during
this conference
at the end of this pandemic european
solidarity will be more necessary than
ever
so that we can together tackle the
social and economic consequences of the
crisis
dear friends make no mistake
without increased
social cohesion the identity
of our societies and the essence
of our democracies would be under threat
i also believe that the time has come to
reflect
on the functioning and identity
of the european parliament
as i said earlier our democratic systems
constantly need to adapt to
the context in which we live
because democracy is built on a daily
basis
we also know that democracy is fragile
and let me remind you all of
the moment at the start of this year
when
all of us were looking to washington
where there was an effort to attack
the american congress the parliament
is the guarantor of democratic values in
the european decision-making process
and that's something that we
particularly need to reflect on
our institution has
705 members
and we represent the pluralism that
exists
in our democracies in our democratic
lives in europe
i think therefore that we have to
reflect
on how we can boost the central role
of the european parliament particularly
with regard to its powers of initiative
as is the case for every national
parliament
the right of initiative should be given
to the european parliament so that our
institution
can make proposals to the commission
and to the council and not just
receive their proposals
this would help to give
the parliament increased capacities
and would improve our democracy
we also need to increase the
transparency of elections
and enable citizens to indicate
their preference for president of the
commission
i hope that the conference will also
deal with the lead candidate
issue because i firmly believe
that this will contribute to citizens
need to be more involved
in the same way it's crucial to look at
the issue of unanimity
in the council as i said earlier
we see that in the world there are
geopolitical players who attack us
and take advantage of our divisions to
weaken us
this contributes
to citizens distrust
and that's something that we have to
fight
because a democracy that can't
respond rapidly is a democracy
that can easily be attacked
there are many proposals many things to
think about every institution
puts forward its own priorities and
citizens
need to help us to understand the spirit
of the times
which requires more europe
all these reflections and those that
emerge from our citizens
may well need an update of our treaties
and i would ask everyone if that's the
case
to be brave to be generous
there should be no taboos and we
shouldn't be afraid
and it's in that spirit that we will
hold these discussions so that we can
find the responses
that our societies require of us
personally i firmly believe
that the awareness of our unity and a
common destiny
is shared by the majority of our
citizens
now more than ever because many people
have become aware that without
europe's initiatives without the
european
policy all our countries all our
communities
and our citizens would be weaker
together let's build a stronger
more resilient and more democratic
and more united europe that's the
message
that we need to send out from here in
strasbourg today
the capital of the european union and i
think
this is the message that
can push our citizens
to give us the responses we need thank
you
europe is a multifaceted and
polyphonic continent and what better way
to
illustrate that then europavox
europavox was born 15 years ago
with two main goals in mind first
to help european music talents to travel
and spread their songs all over the
continent
and to help music lovers to discover
great new artists
we should also say that
the 9th of may on europe day
there's always a concert there'll be a
concert on
seven o'clock this evening online this
is the second
edition of music europe day 12 european
artists
who are passionate about music and you
can watch the concert it's available to
everyone on the facebook page
it brings together european people and
breaks down
walls and these talented young people
have something to say about the culture
in europe and now we listen to their
[Music]
music
[Music]
m
[Music]
foreign
the dream europe is happening
it's also movement yeah it's it's it's
constant movement
it's it's constant constant being alive
as european
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i would love europe to be even more
diverse and to be respectful
about this diversity
[Applause]
in terms of culture and stuff i mean one
of my favorite things about
europe in general is this kind of you
know the idea that everybody brings
their own thing
into an area and i'd love to see more
and more of that basically kind of
the cultures kind of mixing together and
introducing people into new stuff all
the way
hey hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
our next speaker has just arrived
from the city of porto yesterday
he chaired uh
a social summit to european social
summit
today we have antonio costa welcome
prime minister of portugal and is here
to speak to us about this summit
this invitation to european citizens to
be involved in discussions about
how we want to organize the union and
how we want to
live together in europe in the future
rotating presidency of the eu that this
joint initiative
by the european parliament's european
commission and the european council
takes flight it's quite a feat to
accomplish
to get all these institutions working
together
with the citizens prime minister costa
prime minister costa you have the flaw
double thank you very much
president of the french republic
president of the european parliament
president of the european commission
european citizens it's a pleasure to be
here
today with uh president david sesoli
and ursula von der lion in
the official opening of the conference
on the future
of europe
european people across our countries
are facing up to the pandemic there have
been
horrific consequences both social and
economic
this official launch of the conference
on the future of europe
is a message of confidence in the future
that we want to convey to all
citizens of europe
why are we having this conference on the
future of europe
the answer and it may seem strange to
you
was given by one of the great european
poets of the 16th century luis de
comoise
in one of his most famous poems
he said times change desires
change people change confidence change
everything the whole world is made up of
changes we always need to develop new
qualities
so let's start with the beginning
times change desires change 71 years
now 71 years have passed since the
schumann declaration which we celebrate
on the 9th of may
as europe day throughout these 71 years
our will our desire has
changed europe
for a long time now we have been more
than the six
countries who want to set up a steel and
coal community the eu
has been growing our desire has been
common to do more we've been
extending the eu to new
accessions and new and more diversity
this is
a success story that we can be proud of
now everything seems clear obvious
even brexit seemed irreversible
history is not linear though
whenever we deepen or expand
the eu it led to difficult
choices and meant that we needed to find
compromise we needed a lot of
persistence and we needed to be creative
we didn't always move together move
forward together or at the same time
with schengen and the euro
clearly illustrate we still haven't
fully
concluded all of the steps that we've
already given
both with schengen and euro uh
shows quite clearly we should not
forget this
there is a desire to move forward but we
should not
allow problems to exist which can
undermine our
cohesion we need to address
the key issues if we want to be
successful
and we have to be successful
we cannot avoid the difficult issues
today there are a range of debates
ongoing about
what the eu should be
these debates are not limited to
certain states and and moving states but
they are dividing societies
in many of our member states
the eu has come forward
a long way but we're still far away from
where we need to be
we are above all a community of
fundamental values
or are we just an economic space which
uh
has added value with its integration how
do we
judge these common values how do we
ensure that they are in line with
national requirements as well how do we
link
national interests with solidarity
for example how do we share resources
or how do we do this in terms of
managing
migration the conference on the future
of europe
is an opportunity to address these
issues frankly and openly
we don't all think the way that we used
to think
new times require new ways of
of working our desire changes
over times and we want more things
the lisbon treaty was
careful it provided for the necessary
flexibility
via passero clauses and also
reinforced cooperation mechanisms so
that we didn't have to
face up a dramatic
um problems if
if there were different opinions then it
allowed for certain people certain
member states to do
more or to do things more quickly we
have
common values that are not
relative for example the rule of law
gender equality but there are
elsewhere different matrices which are
open
to everything we want to see
full participation on basis of objective
criteria
this will allow us to build the future
with necessary unity and clearly
diversity this conference
therefore should focus on all the
different desires and worlds of all the
citizens
in europe and not on negotiations
between countries
this is a conference for citizens by
citizens
and four citizens
now let's move on to the second verse
over
it says
beings change and trust change
the fire the most recent euro barometer
report is very clear
it says that the eu's response to
the covid crisis has
placed the european union
at the highest level in relation to the
amount of trust
that uh people have in it well done uh
this time the success of the eu
in looking after its citizens has been
very clear
we have seen the europeans
did not feel abundant they
were all considered as equal
we can draw conclusions from this
firstly european citizens
recognize uh the added value of eu
action secondly we can say that european
citizens
want the eu to focus their efforts
on a direct response to specific
problems that citizens face
over the past 10 years a huge
number of major topics are continually
quoted
as sources of concern
defense of freedom against the terrorist
threat
the economic and social situation
and climate change
migration as well
is an issue that is of concern to people
it is not surprising therefore that over
the past 12 months
health has also come
a major concern for europe citizens
another very important point nine out of
ten
europeans want a social europe
if we want europe to have a future
then europe needs to build on its
strengths
and needs to build on the strength of
its citizenry
we need more than just
um certain parts we need to ensure vast
citizen participation
this is a key uh
point the conference on the future of
europe should focus on
the women and men of europe what is
trouble
drawing is troubling these people what
is making them dream
this should not be an exercise which is
uh based in brussels it should be member
states regions municipalities
all local and regional authorities
should be
involved in promoting the citizen
dialogue in a decentralized manner
we need to think of future generations
we should not think of future meetings
or the next
top jobs or the next treaty
europe will have no future
if our young generations do not have a
future
in europe these
the s very high youth
unemployment rate a segmented
labor market the difficulties for access
to housing
are creating obstacles for the future of
our young generation
the largest threat to the future of
europe and to the prosperity of europe
is the aging population
those people who think that immigrants
are a threat for a demographic balance
are wrong the demographic
threat that we face today
is our incapacity to guarantee for young
people
the possibility of being free
to decide what they want to do with
their lives
now let me go back to luis de comanche
the third verse of his poem
is made of change
the european union is not alone in the
world
and must not isolate itself
on the contrary the eu
must change to keep pace with the world
the strategic autonomy that we must
pursue
must be the autonomy of europe open to
the world
diversifying our partners defending
multilateralism standing up
for our values and our standards
we must therefore take the lead
in the major causes of humanity
in our century if europe
wants to be global it cannot be
confined to its continental
dimension the portuguese presidency
will propose that we work within the
european union
on a global agenda for the oceans
2050. the oceans
are a common heritage of humanity
the oceans are the most important
climate regulator
the oceans needs urgent protection
and the oceans are an immense
source of biodiversity
and resources others
have given priority to the moon
or to mars but
europe must embrace oceans
as a cause and our great mission
for the next decade
because the oceans covered the largest
area of our planet but remain
a great unknown we have used the oceans
as bridge between continents and peoples
to trade to develop knowledge
but we have forgotten the immense
territory
that remains to discover in the oceans
themselves it's this
unknown that we want to discover
to preserve and value
we must say rewarding president kennedy
in 1962
we choose to go to the oceans
and now let's move on to the fourth and
final verse
of karmansha's poem
we always need to develop new qualities
more than just a a common currency
a customs union or a single currency
europe
has been and will remain a community of
values
it's a space with a unique social model
we have protection and provide equality
of opportunity
for all
this is something that where there's no
concessions the future of europe should
be built on the fundamental values of
freedom democracy human rights
civil rights and economic and social
rights
we will only be able to conserve
our identity if we add
new qualities we need to build on the
opportunities that we have ahead of us
we started this journey 71 years ago
with
coal and steel the basis of the economy
at the time
now we need to begin once again
in green and digital the drivers
of uh recovery plans for the future
i'd like to conclude uh
with a quote from mario suwat father of
uh
portuguese democracy and an ardent
uh european and a former mep in this
very
chamber
in 1976 he highlighted
or alerted us of the problem which is
very
current building
europe is not going to be an easy task
there's going to be many obstacles which
will be in our way
and some of them will be born from
traditions which are linked to
collective
lives of different peoples rethinking
europe and thinking of its future
is an ongoing obligation this should be
assumed
with humility faced with the historic
importance of the aims and it should be
a task
for all europeans
that's why rather than looking for
change
european citizens need to be those who
create this change and build this change
and i'd like to
give my final words to the people over
here to those of you present here today
and the thousands who are connected
online
this conference is open it's open
so that all of you can participate in it
third presentee
come forward with your priorities your
dreams
so that together we can build
the future of europe thank you very much
[Applause]
obligatory mercy thank you mr president
for this
speech in three languages of the eu
you speak french like all those on
this panel do and multi lingualism
is a feature of all of those who will be
joining us
today europe understands it itself
better
it speaks many languages so now our next
guest is
a star violinist he is a soloist who has
played with
many orchestras he hasn't had many
concerts
during the last pandemic as has been the
case for many artists and so we've seen
him
playing in supermarkets for example you
may well have seen him
while you were shopping but he's here
capisson recorded an extensive set of
discs covering a wide range of music
from baktok over others to film music
even renu capisson will play for us
meditation de tais from an opera by the
french composer
jul masone it's a story about the lures
of a life
of pleasure and luxury in contrast with
a more
spiritual life enjoy
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey
[Music]
ah
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
hey
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
mmm
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Applause]
a breath of fresh air
soul food ladies and gentlemen
this is an interesting point in time
european debates got closer to home
over the past few years whether it's
about the vaccine strategy
or green passports to allow us to travel
this summer
whether it is about the freedom of
speech or social justice
or climate change the eu has a role to
play
and the impact or lag thereof
on each of our lives fuels the
discussions from north to south from
east
to west and vice versa the next speaker
is bound to invite you to lean in
to get a seat at a table to make your
voice
hurt madam president of the european
commission josela from the lion
the floor is yours
prime minister costa ladies and
gentlemen dear
european citizens
i am delighted to finally be back
here in strasbourg
for what is a very special europe day
this city symbolizes a major chunk of
our history
it is only normal therefore that we
should be here
to speak about our future and when
i think of this future and of this
conference
am reminded of a former strasbourg
resident
antoine de santiago perry and
particularly his
book the earth of men
published just before the second world
war
in his unique and poetic style
he gave life to the emotions of fear
and pain love and hope
that live in each and every one of us
he reminds us of the importance of
living alongside
one another but also alongside the
natural world that surrounds us
and our duty to hand over
a better world to our children
although the backdrop today is different
what he says to us rings true for
today's world
there's a particular quote that
resonates for me because it represents
what europe is about
and the duty of this conference and i
quote
to love one another is not about
gazing into each other's eyes it is
about looking together
in the same direction
ladies and gentlemen this
is the task and the opportunity ahead of
all of us
the conference is for all europeans to
debate a shared vision
of what we want of our union
of course i'm conscious that there's
always skepticism
and cynicism wherever europe debates its
future
or launches a project of this nature
so we must ensure it is not an
intellectual policy exercise
or close political compromise
we should be honest that the conference
is not a panacea
or a solution to every problem
and we must listen to all voices
whether critical or complementary
and ensure that we properly follow up on
whatever is agreed
but i do believe that this conference
is a real opportunity to bring
europeans together and to rally around
the common ambition
for our future just as previous
generations did
and we should also not underestimate the
power of
good that it could do for people
individually
and for society as a whole
the point is that the european union
must be
whatever europeans want it to be
of course the start of the conference
is not the time to predict or prescribe
outcomes
but there are certain dichotomies and
issues that we should attempt to resolve
for example some feel
europe is too close and too involved in
their lives
and for others it is far too far away
and too remote and too detached this
is an opportunity for europeans to help
find the right balance
for some europe is too institutional
and mechanical in the way that it works
this is an opportunity to see how we can
simplify
and make it more down to earth where it
is needed
for some the narrative of peace
is not as compelling as for others
this is an opportunity to help
build a new common purpose for
all europeans
we see how important that is when we
look at the world around us
globalized but fragmented
full of contradictions and
confrontations
it reminds us of the importance of a
shared sense of
purpose and that none of us
can go it alone
the pandemic has been traumatic for
people in europe and around the world
it will be a formative part of so many
lives
and of so many parts of society
and like all trauma we need to find a
way
to talk about it if we want to move
beyond it
and there's no better way to do that
than by offering perspective
hope and the ability to change things
for the better
and this is why i believe
it is such an important moment
for young people in particular
to have their say
this pandemic stole more than a year
from them it stole experiences
and emotions that every young person
needs
it still fun and friendship that shaped
people forever
it stole opportunities from them to grow
to learn and to take risks
and more than anything it made so many
people
older young feel anxious
lonely and simply less in control of
their lives and their future
for the first time in a generation more
people worry
that their children will not be better
off than them
this shows that we need a new form of
solidarity
and social justice between generations
this is about justice and rights
not only within our current society
but across the generations
the recent groundbreaking court rulings
in several member states reflect this
they talk about the responsibility
to take clear action to address our over
exploitation of nature
and the environment
we can't give young people back the time
that has been taken away from them by
the pandemic
but we can rebuild better
and in a fairer manner for and with them
we need to act now and young people
must play a central role in this change
the change the challenge excuse me is a
major one
paradoxically an awful lot needs to
change
so that the conditions for human life
remain the same
fundamental changes are needed to ensure
that the next generations can still
enjoy
nature we need to change
so that our grandchildren can still
experience spring
summer autumn and winter
but fundamental change does not come
about via court rulings
but via politics
and that's why i believe we should use
this conference
in order to hold a genuine structured
structured
dialogue between the generations so that
we can discuss
how we can protect the fundamental
conditions needed for life
there is as much at stake as there was
in 1950
schuman made his declaration
at the time he was looking at the
desolation and destruction caused by war
but let's not kill ourselves
there is just as much at stake now
because climate change can rapidly
produce
the same destructive effects as a war
beyond this is that europe has
always been at its best when it is
reverse engineered
we are at our boldest when we first set
an ambitious goal
or have to act out of necessity
often without competence or precedence
this is the europe that rises to the
challenge
the europe that just does it because it
needs to be done
it is not so long ago that the
environment was a fringe
or a peripheral issue for the european
union
but it is now the most central
issue for our generation and for the
generations to come
madame
for example ladies and gentlemen
showing the example showing empathy
towards young people since the beginning
of the pandemic is a source of
inspiration to us giving us hope and a
sense of responsibility
that we need to build a better world
it was just barely a month ago that
i got a very very emotional
reminder of that when i became a
grandmother
for the very first time the first
caress with my young granddaughter
was one of those moments
that really really allows you to get
your priorities right
and reminds you of what really matters
in life
during that moment of tenderness of love
she showed me one thing
that we must never forget that we
always owe it to the world to allow them
to believe in the world
and we are old enough to make that
difference happen
this is what brings generations
together holding
this little creature in my arms
i did what all new parents and new
grandparents do
and always have done i thought of
all of the opportunities and i tried to
imagine the kind of world that she would
grow up in
would there be forests will there be any
fauna left or maybe it will only be
remaining in history books or films what
will
jobs look like what about technology
that she will need
and inequalities and social disparity
will they be worse or
better and what will europa
do what will she defend in her life
will she be respectful more diversified
mo united or will she be divided
as often we were in the past these
matters may seem
too large or too distant whereas
there are so many immediate challenges
however
the course of our action
will determine the answers that we will
be looking for tomorrow and that's
precisely why
we need this conference and why
we need to get it started now
we will tackle this task with humility
recognizing that not everything is ideal
but also with a real sense of proud
knowing where we're coming from and
the conviction of what must be done at
all times
and i will conclude
where i started with antoine de santiage
once again
because he inspired jean-marie with his
sentence
the most beautiful profession a man can
have
is that of bringing men together
it's up to us now to keep on
doing that thank you long live europe
[Applause]
thank you very much president
the 430 million europeans
have been in lockdown now for a year to
address
the effects of a virus that has had a
massive
impact on people's daily lives jobs
transport
their mood of course and now
they can draw the lessons from this
unprecedented
event they can see what will happen
in terms of the economy and also perhaps
in terms of philosophy
indeed because admit it so far
there has been a lot of talk about
european citizens
people on stage have been talking to you
but it's high time to draw you in
and let's hear from what you have to say
so let's listen to some of you
[Music]
i was born in 1940
so for me the european union is
important
and indispensable as a guarantor of
peace
my hope for the future of europe is that
europe
can play its role in the world
sustainably
and efficiently
my hope for the future of europe is that
at a central level all decisions whether
political or economic will be guided
by ecology and the environment
[Music]
i think that the european union should
focus more on innovation
in order to address global challenges
and not just technological innovation
but also social innovation because the
real magic happens
at the interface between social and
technological innovation
adjusting this inability to naturally
innovate to promote creativity in
important areas like digitization big
tech and so on
will hold the european union back both
economically and politically
it needs to find ways to give these
companies space
to allow startups to grow and become
global
competitors
i hope that my children will live in a
country
and in europe that respects their life
choices
their worldview and i hope that europe
will defend the democratic values
of the country where my children settle
adventure i would like an accessible
europe
that is not just labeled accessible on
paper
but actually become genuinely accessible
in inclusive europe that takes people
just
as they are
[Music]
i think that to improve the european
union
we need to put more trust into young
people young
foreigners and immigrants
because a lot of us come here to do
great things
to achieve our dreams and all we need
is a little helping hand
we always have many hopes and dreams for
our children
i'm really happy that my kids now live
in in europe
being a part of the european community
they have much more possibilities
[Music]
my hope for the future of europe as a
practicing pharmacist
is to have a common health policy in
face of pandemics or other threats
which really benefit the citizens and as
healthcare providers
we have the tools we concretely need on
the ground
ladies and gentlemen this conference on
the future of europe should lead
to practical recommendations suggestions
and ideas for change in the european
union
and to make sure that all this work your
work
and input will fall into the right ears
and will be followed up upon an
executive board of the conference on the
future of europe
has been installed co-chaired by our
next guests
hello
you're a member of the european
parliament you're a former belgian prime
minister
and you are the co-president of the
conference
on the parliament side ana paula
zakarias is
minister for european affairs
in portugal who represents the council
as part of this trio and then finally we
have dubravka switzer representing the
european
commission commissioner responsible for
demography europeans
wanted to ask you questions very brief
direct question
and we're going to begin with adessa
moon who is a film director she's 52 she
comes from romania
and she's going to ask you a question on
a europe of culture or european culture
please listen to her question mr foster
how can we have a true european culture
was a very short question
no i i think that uh look climate change
was never
a competence of the european union it
became a competence of the european
union health was not competence of the
european union because of coffee it
became a competence
of the european union and i think that
culture could also
be a competence of the european union
arts culture education youth so
for me it exists when i when i listen to
uh or i read goethe for me that's not a
german philosopher for me that's a
european
philosopher and thing voltaire and the
enlightenment
uh are the same when i go to uh to to
strasbourg or to firenze
president sarsouri i feel myself in
in european city more than an italian
city or something like that so i think
that we have
to put that interaction until now we
don't do it and also because uh
it's it's it has to do with our emotions
and that can be in small things
uh not only big things but also small
things but for example our banknotes
from the euro that are this uh
drownings that are purely theoretical
bridges why not putting our beautiful
european monuments the notre dame the
ponte vecchio on our banknotes
or for example another thing we go to
the olympic games all together
why not or athletes in their outfits
having here the national flag why not
their
their european flag it's in small things
but these small things counts certainly
for those generations in the future so
culture
needs to be in the heart of our project
because it's the
most solid basis i should say of the
european union
thank you very much for that answer um
mr carias the next question is directed
at you
um it's mine jabil lager
a french high school student of 16 years
old
who wants to know how you feel
about climate change and moreover what
you will do about it let's
hear her say that
what are you doing to maintain the
health of the planet for our generation
i think it's a question that many many
young people
across europe have in mind top of mind
so what's your answer to them
absolutely this is a simple question
that has a complex
answer and that's why we're here that's
why we need all of us
to answer to that incredible simple
question
what are we going to do about the health
of our planet
what are we going to do about our health
because they are together
hand in hand and this is the way we need
to look
at things our health is dependent on our
planet cells
and here i would say three things
basically climate change
we need to address this issue it's
fundamental it's a
it's a it's a lifeline that we have so
the european union has been at the
forefront of this
we establish climate neutrality for 2050
and we have the first climate law with
the
binding elements so we want to achieve
in
uh 2030 at least a reduction in 55
of our carbon emissions then we need to
look at
oceans like my prime minister just said
oceans are fundamental
they are the essence of life so we need
to do
more about the oceans then we need to
look uh and do more about
energy efficiency and we are doing that
and we are also doing more about
renewable energies and there are
other elements biodiversity we
thrive in the world because it's
biodiverse
this is fundamental issue and we are now
having very soon
an international conference on this the
world has to come together it's not just
the union is the world that has to come
together to promote biodiversity
fight against deforestation and finally
another word that comes into this
equation needs
what do we need how many t-shirts do we
need
for what so council the the patterns
of consumption are a very fundamental
element in all this
and uh it is important to see the cycles
of production
it is very important to see um design
uh they how are we going to use these
products
resources are limited and they need to
be
better distributed so these are the
fundamental elements that we have to
look
into institutions member states
but also the citizens they need to be in
the driving cities
uh so that we know what to do please
tell us what would be
the main challenges that you see in this
context
difficult and complex answers needs
everybody for to build them thank you
very much
hello madame switzer mrs
sweet now a question from anna anderson
she's a 39 year old business
woman who comes from latvia
and she is
a member of the board of rigatech girls
so a female entrepreneur but she's very
interested in
issues that relate to diversity which
i'm sure you'll be interested in as well
because
your portfolio which relates to
democracy also depends on diversity
let's say the question
how can europe promote diversity
considering
the unavoidable immigration different
cultures
and an aging society thank you i want to
thank anna for this question
what a better place than strasbourg to
show that europe is promoting diversity
having in mind the history of strasbourg
and history of these two states
diversity is united in diversity is our
european motto
so it's not only motto but we live in
diversity and when
mentioning immigration i want to remind
all of you that all of us are strangers
somewhere in the world
either strangers or foreigners once
wherever you go
you will be somewhere in one part of the
world stranger
so europe is open europe uh wants to be
open we want to have open doors because
we think
that we have to help people who have to
flee from violence or from
other other reasons so uh definitely
we are on this uh the question is okay
and i
think we are we are promoting this
uh i saw that uh also uh solidarity
is very important because we we heard a
lot from our four
presidents so maybe to mention once
again
inter uh generational solidarity is
very important because we have to learn
we have many young people
here today and it's very good and one
third of all our panels will have to be
comprised of one-third of young people
from 16 to 25
but we have also to listen to older
people because
older people have wisdom all the people
have experience
and we have also to listen to them so
intergenerational solidarity
i think is one of our goals and i'm sure
that all of you both young and older
people will engage
in this conference because citizens
engagement is for us ultimate goal
we want citizens to be in the heart of
this process of course alongside with
institutions
but we need citizens to listen to them
to see what are their ideas
and to try to comply with their with
their ideas because sometimes
there is a small gap between us
policymakers and citizens so we want to
narrow this gap we want to come closer
and this is the very idea of this
conference and i want to thank all of
you
for your speeches because everything was
has already been said
okay next question is for you mr
verhofstadt from
martina petriniak she's an architect and
a
bookshop owner in croatia somewhere
she's in her 50s
and she has a question for you regarding
something that i know is close to your
heart
freedom of expression and the freedom to
be who you
really are this is something not only at
stake in relation to other parts of the
world but also within
europe of course let's hear how she puts
it
what does european union do in order to
enlarge freedoms and
values to the rest of the world with
these values do not exist
what about those who fight for such
freedoms
i think we need to recognize that as
things stand today
freedom of expression
and the liberal democracy and everything
that that stands for
human rights is becoming more of a
an obvious issue in the world the major
power is
sometimes saying the mirror opposite and
that
we need to look towards the european
model when it comes to what's happening
currently in china
the democracy of millions of people in
hong kong
going to be totally smashed
because of the regime of the communist
party in china
look at what's happening it's the same
thing in russia
i increasingly think that it's a police
state without even for journalists any
possibility
of doing their job i mean
it's no longer something that just
happens and uh the president of the
commission said it uh
we play a geopolitical role defending
our ideals and i think there will be a
need
to try a bit harder and i want to hear
from the citizens
uh because it's all about the citizens
uh
are they prepared to take that step to
make that effort
to defend our values not just within
uh there are also other things to say
but uh
but of course i don't want to upset our
sense of celebration
but when there are sanctions that need
to be taken
against mr putin or against his
oligarchs
or well we don't get unanimity we need
to drop it because otherwise it will
take months or to have a free trade
agreement with countries that don't
respect our values
blatantly and well to dream just a bit
about the possibility of one day having
a european army
a long-standing project mr schuman that
was one of his ideas
it's not we that pulled it out of a hat
he's the one who came up with it
and currently we're seeing the most
gigantic
wastage in europe when it comes to
military expenditure to give you some
figures uh
the same thing as the chinese spend on
their military
the same thing as europeans we spend
four times more than the russians in
military expenditure and i hardly think
that if russia comes
that we'd be able to stop them certainly
not
with the americans surely but
we need to tackle these points and to
come up with answers we need to put
these questions to decisions are we
prepared to make that effort to
this leap into the future that we
haven't made in the past it must be said
well somebody needs to recognize that
reality
some people shaking their heads no no no
and others yes yes yes
out there that was the goal behind their
screen so i think you've sparked a
debate mr
hosta thank you for that we keep going
with the debate
mrs vice president of the european
commission
uh there is a journalism student of 20
from the netherlands who wants to ask
you about an important value of the eu
that is a transparency
tyres fine and let's have a listen to
what he wants to
husk
[Music]
how can you make sure that future
generations will have a better operating
more
transparent and more democratic european
union
so i want to thank for this question uh
you know the three principles of this
conference
are openness inclusiveness and
transparency so we want to lead this
process in a
really open and transparent way but
regarding
future and the future generations i
already said
we are preparing this europe for future
generations so we don't want to talk
about them we want without them so we
want to talk
about europe with them and this is the
most important
uh for this conference because we want
to include them and to talk with them
about their future
when you think about recovery and
resilience facility for example we call
it popular in next generation eu
which means we are preparing this europe
for next generation but together with
them together
with young people yes strong europe in
the world is important but
this pandemic reminds us of daily issues
first of health then of how we relate to
our nature
what you president wonderland said then
uh
how we relate to our family members now
and how we work together
so this is something which we want our
citizens to
interact with us to deliberate on daily
issues on what matters to their lives i
think this
i cannot preempt what will the results
of the conference be
but i think the citizens will be
interested in
the issues that matter to them of course
institutional matters are also important
but i think this will be but i don't
want to
say more about this because we don't
want to influence
the final result of the conference let's
see but
anyway what is the most important what
is the benchmark of this conference
in comparison to previous conferences
citizens dialogues conventions
is feedback mechanism and follow-up this
is the reason why
we will uh finish our deliberations by
uh
by uh spring next year and then we need
second part of our mandate to follow up
to act accordingly and this is
uh what is what differs and what makes
this conference i hope a success
but if we do this together i hope we
will have a success in the end
but let's see and let's uh let's uh not
impose anything on our citizen let them
talk
and let us listen a little bit okay
thank you very much
it has been mentioned a couple of times
throughout the event mr carrillo's
youngsters young people are at the
center of this debate it's about
their future so to speak um let's listen
to what six
portuguese students say about how they
feel and think about the eu
[Music]
so the fact that people shouldn't have
to be
all the same we're different and that
is a good thing right now it's also
about managing the pandemic
mainly the grand divergences between
countries the challenges that the
community faces
uh uh remaining at preventing climate
change
if i could create a european project i
would probably work in
education most of the time schools
are not enough they can teach his
languages
and mathematics but they felt teachers
about being a good citizen a project
that could reach as many children as we
can
and that could give us a chance to
interact with each other
in a way that we can all experience each
other's cultures
mr carias these are youngsters wanting
to work together wanting to learn more
about
each other but i also noticed they are
worried about the divergence and the
growing apart
among member states what do you say to
them
these young portuguese students are
mentioning
many areas above all they are asking as
to look at
diversity and to see diversity as
something positive
the motto of the european union is
united in diversity
diversity is positive it brings us
greater capacity greater adaptability
greater flexibility
this diversity is extremely important it
helps us to welcome
migrants to welcome those who are
excluded and to ensure that we're
leaving no one behind
they have also spoken about
multiculturalism they've spoken about
education they also spoke about
something which is very important
the importance of having in schools
information about europe
so young people in schools can work on
issues around
europe so they can discuss it so they
can have a stage to bring forward their
ideas not just in this conference on the
future of europe but
on a daily basis so people know more
about europe and they can give us
more feedback about europe
i would say that they are right we need
to look for their future
i also agree with dubravka says that we
can't forget the older people as well
we can't forget that people have had
difficult lives we can't
forget those who have been excluded
those who are different
we also need to take those into
consideration
and those who don't have uh internet so
they can't log on to this
i think we need to welcome and take in
all of these ideas we need to work on
them
and that's what the conferences is here
for
and that well the future is in your
hands
thank you to all three of you for these
responses
[Applause]
this brings us to the
conclusion of this event in strasbourg
thank you uh
to president macron uh
president surly prime minister koster
mrs from the commissioner from the lion
and thank you for having come here and
launched this conference on the future
thank you
to you too of course the three co-chairs
of the executive board of the conference
giver hofstadt dubravka suicia and anna
maria zakarias
and thanks to everyone out there you
look brilliant on the screens to be
honest
very colorful very involved thank you so
much for watching this event yeah an
applause to you
via the screens you look brilliant
hello
[Applause]
so if to take part you have to go onto
the platform
future europa point eu and we're going
to conclude with some music
the anthem of europe this is a very
popular spanish
version by miguel rios who has recruited
various people
from the world of culture well-known
sports personalities you may well
recognize some of them
so this is the ode to joy revisited by
claude so this will conclude this
ceremony but will open
the page to your active participation in
the european construction
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
awesome foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
these
[Music]
is
[Music]
so
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
you